elle a dormi deux heures et demie c'est
nathalie saint cricq la madone et la
politique on ne se voit pas les
maquilleuses sont là et vous serez avec
toi quelques minutes pour décrypter ces
législatives et ce second tour il est
exactement 7 heures on retrouve
nathanaël de rincquesen
au le journal à la une la contre
performance du parti présidentiel au
second tour des législatives
ensemble arrive en tête certes mais
n'atteint pas la majorité absolue de 289
sièges le parti des bagnoles macro on
est même loin avec 245 sièges ces
résultats inédits sous la vème
république pose la question de la
capacité du chef de l'état à pouvoir
gouverner et faire voter les réformes il
se produire pour terminator
[Musique]
terminator j'étais sur le plateau de
certains de vos confrères et j'ai même
vu un appel du pied de mât d'un pneu
monsieur pardon dupond moretti en
direction notamment d'un prêt d'un
représentant mais peut-être que sur mon
prochain budget vous pourriez le voter
etc et lançant un appel au rassemblement
national pour qui est en accord sur
certains sujets deux mois plus tard ils
sont en train de nous expliquer qu'ils
vont peut-être faire alliance avec le
rassemblement rassemblement national
j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya beaucoup de
français qui sont très contents ce moyen
ils sont très contents parce que il
retrouve de l'allant de la démocratie
dans le parlement ça qd il retrouve sa
ils ont été un supporter par
effectivement un président qui décide et
de tous toujours et tout le temps sur le
co vide qui prenait la parole à 20h qui
faisait 17 millions de gens quand ils
disaient vous allez porter un masque
vous allez faire ceci vous aide ils en
ont marre
elle l'ancienne femme de chambre connaît
déjà sa mission sur les bancs de
l'assemblée j'ai su la voix des sans
voix je suis femme dé chambre femme de
ménage agents de sécurité aide soignante
aide à domicile je suis tous ses métiers
et bible
damien abad qui me faisaient qu'à ceux
ci bras oui oh non non mobilisation pour
sa réélection à bien dans la finalement
prendre un verre d'eau et le boire c'est
pas donné à tout le monde la preuve à
peut pas le faire tout seul et moi j'ai
la chance de pour le faire pendant et
soif ok j'ai compris le message donc
voilà pour la fragilité d'accord j'ai
compris le message
super non j'utilise en piste alors ok
très nombreux plans d'eau toilette aussi
conviés
j'ai monté un meuble chez lui
y'avait pas toilettes
j'ai dû faire pipi dans la douche
je me suis vu maintenant dans le rouge
et percuté faire voilà voilà je suis
mariée
vous souvenez de 1000 euros c'est pour
refaire les toilettes oui et quand vous
partez en vacances vous regardez sur les
sites internet où sont les c'est quoi le
problème c'est pas un problème c'est pas
la pièce la plus importante de la maison
je comprends pas alors il faut qu'ils en
aient c'est sûr encore nous on peut
toujours se débrouiller avec un lavabo
invite fait ainsi en cas de vie d'annie
et désormais enfermés dans un bureau
avec ses conseillers à laitages de ce
bar où nous nous trouvons mais pour
l'heure en partie dans voix d'écart à la
défaveur de cédric villani personnes ce
soir ne fiscalise ce résultat
effectivement si tu es toujours là c'est
irréaliste et ville avec
[Applaudissements]
ses bons scolastique vous avez terminé
ceux qui ne sont pas accrédités je vais
demander tout fait sur le quorum tout
alors je nous comme d'hab on reste
derrière le grillage on a pu assister au
test sont avec une technique originale
aurait dû de céréales issues des bras
s'agiter localement en nourriture pour
leurs nerfs
réalisé vers tout se transforme
[Musique]
et oui pour vérifier qu'un micro marche
bien on lit le pack de bières babet les
républicains peuvent faire une majorité
non la nouvelle peut faire une majorité
n'ont hélas ne pèsera pas s'associer au
rassemblement national donc il n'y a pas
d'alternative à l'idée d'une majorité
qui part de qu'on s'appelle ensemble
pardon c'est en
forme avec vous on s'en remettra
et puis un résultat qui peut faire un
peu sourire dans la troisième
circonscription de l'oise regardez c'est
monsieur sabatou qui a battu madame l'a
battu voilà monsieur sabatou qui est élu
et que 52% des voix contre
47 58 monsieur sabato qui est un nouveau
député rassemblement national